c'est quoi ça non mais c'est une
météorite
c'était clairement une météorite venez
voir à l'ats péter l'invite l'a
carrément non mais c'est pas plutôt toi
qui as pété la vitre là parce qu'on
vient d'entendre et puis t'as du verre
partout
tu fais quoi avec un avis aux unités un
quoi
[Musique]
j'aurais quand même réparer l'avis de la
haut parce que je me caille en l'air il
passe sous la porte
on a déjà du mal à payer loyer je suis
pas sûr que ce soit notre priorité en
fait on n'a qu'à vendre la météorite
on peut pas vendre les météorites comme
ça au revoir la météorite mais on dit
que c'est une pierre magique
allez moi je vais faire l'annoncent sur
le bon coin et c'est un mensonge
[Musique]
tout le monde est déjà utilisée ou moins
entendu l'expression publicité
mensongère
de manière générale on considère que la
publicité mensongère c'est quand une
marque communique des choses fausses sur
son produit pour nous induire en erreur
exemple le plus connu c'est de dire que
la meilleure des façons son super gros
sur l'affiché tout est dégueu et moche
une fois servi mais la publicité mon
sourire qu'est ce que c'est précisément
qui fait ça pour quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on peut y faire tant de
questions déjà ça englobe beaucoup de
choses parce que ça désigne la
communication sous toutes ses formes
visons avant quelque chose donc tout ce
qui se pose de pub les affiches etc mais
aussi un vendeur pas ce qui peut vous
induire en erreur volontairement ou
présentant un produit de manière fausse
ensuite bas il faut distinguer la
publicité mensongère de la publicité
trompeuse par exemple étiqueté une
boisson contenant des additifs par la
formule pur jus de fruits la publicité
trompeuse c'est en fait le cas le plus
courant est le plus complexe on
considère qu'une publicité trompeuse
lorsque les éléments sont exacts mais
que leur présentation laisse croire à
des qualités inexistant on peut être
trompeur par omission aussi en oubliant
d'intégrer dans sa communication des
informations qui sont considérées comme
importantes pour le consommateur par
exemple sur un site de commande objets
en ligne vous pouvez voir une photo de
ce genre avec le nom d'articles
télévision au prix de 5 euros
là vous commandez mais il s'avère qu'en
effet c'était une fausse télévision
miniature alors bien sûr vous faire la
différence avec les plus usitées exagéré
par leur caractère créatif
volontairement excessif qui ne constitue
bien sûr pas une infraction
en gros tu dois savoir déterminer si la
publicité consiste à durrës délibérément
le consommateur en erreur et c'est
l'accès compliqué parce que mensonge
peut être volontaire mais aussi
maladroits ou simplement une imprécision
causée par un manque de vigilance
on peut également parler de publicité
déloyale aux plus précisément de
concurrence
rien c'est quand par exemple une marque
d'aspirateurs va se présenter comme la
plus efficace du marché et prendre des
parts de marché grâce à ce message là
une marque concurrente d'aspirateurs va
pouvoir la poursuivre en disant ya rien
qui prouve que leur aspirateur la plus
efficace que le nôtre donc ils peuvent
pas dire ça en bref la publicité
mensongère ça désigne beaucoup de choses
et seulement certains cas sont punis par
la loi et à différents niveaux selon les
cas on va donc commencer par savoir
lesquels quels sont les moyens pour le
consommateur de réagir à ça et quelles
sont les peines encourues pour les
marques
tu vas endroit n'est pas toujours sur un
pied d'égalité votent ya des situations
en a un qui a forcément l'ascendant sur
l'autre d'un salarié par exemple avec
son employeur ben ya un rapport de force
qui se crée et c'est un peu pareil pour
le consommateur on va considérer que
c'est la partie faible au contrat c'est
comme ça qu'on dit en droit et du coup
on va essayer de le protéger au maximum
et on a même un code de la consommation
qui a été fait pour vraiment protéger le
consommateur et a par exemple les
contrats d'adhésion en fait où tu vas
pas du tout pouvoir négocier enfin c'est
soit tu acceptes soit tu vas chez le
concurrent
mais tu pourras pas du tout négocier le
prix use en choses par exemple un
opérateur téléphonique
tu vas pas comment ça veut dire vous
pouvez me faire moins cher ou autre
chose
donc c'est pour ça qu'on essaie de
protéger le consommateur au maximum du
coup la pratique commerciale trompeuse
en fait on va essayer de soi de
désinformation qui sont faux soit qui
sont parcellaires pour essayer de jouer
sur le le consentement du consommateur
et du coup de le tromper
donc on appelle ça vicié son
consentement tu veux rendre au et c'est
pour ça que des fois il ya par exemple
des des assauts de consommateurs qui
vont se constituer avec des personnes
qui ont été victimes et qui vont faire
ce qu'on appelle des actions de groupe
et ça c'était pas toujours possible
c'est possible depuis de 2014 alors aux
états unis franchement on a vraiment
l'habitude de ça mais en france c'est
assez nouveau et c'est super dans
l'actualité en fait parce que tu vois
bien que le consommateur il va pas
forcément agir contre un opérateur
téléphonique tout seul alors que bas ici
sont 100 ou 1000 à avoir une même
problème mais ils auront vraiment une
force de frappe
à l'époque c'était beaucoup moins
surveillés que soient par les
consommateurs ou même par la loi après
tout dans les années 50 aux états unis
on utilisait la figure d'autorité du
médecin pour communiquer que les
cigarettes n'était pas mauvaise pour la
santé
on dit souvent que le petit déjeuner est
le repas le plus important de la journée
et cela viendrait la diététicienne les
l'aef cooper qui l'aurait écrit en 1917
dans le magazine good life magazine
appartenant au docteur et nutritionniste
john harvey kellogg est connu surtout
pour avoir inventé les célèbres corn
flakes commercialisé par son frère à
partir de 1907 sentant plus tard
beaucoup d'études ont été menées depuis
et aucune n'a pu trouver une seule
preuve soutenant l'idée que la
consommation d'un petit déjeuner promeut
la perte de poids ça pourrait même avoir
l'effet inverse
aujourd'hui la loi est beaucoup plus
vigilantes et les consommateurs ont des
outils pour se faire entendre avec les
réseaux sociaux à bad buzz est vite
arrivé les eaux sociaux ont fait évoluer
le rapport entre les marques et les
consommateurs une relation verticale où
la marque
au dessus et le consommateur en dessous
vers une relation horizontale ou les
sont sur le même pied d'égalité
d'où la grande tendance de la
transparence des marques apparu dans les
années 2010 par sa consommateurs avec le
bon poste ont bon moment peut détruire
l'image d'une marque une erreur peut
simplement venir d'un seul employé de la
marque indépendamment de cette dernière
quand lorsqu un livreur de dominos avait
été surpris en train de cracher dans une
pizza avant de la donner à un client
la vidéo avait évidemment tournés et
indigné sur les réseaux sociaux pour
comprendre ça il est important de savoir
que pour une marque qui lie à l'identité
de marque et l'image de marque et ce
n'est pas la même chose l'identité de
marque et comment la marque souhaite
apparaître selon la stratégie qui a été
établie en interne tandis que l'image de
marque c'est l'image réelle perçu
naturellement par le public et la
publicité elle va justement servir à
influencer l'image de marco en tête les
gens pour qu'elle ressemble plus
possible à l'identité de marque prévu
mais du coup faire la publicité
mensongère c'est sûrement la pire chose
à faire pour ça parce que même si sur le
court terme dire que son produit est
plus incroyable qu'il ne les fera
beaucoup plus de ventes sur le long
terme l'image de la marque bel va être
déplorable les marques qui pèse le plus
sur le marché et qui sont installés
depuis des décennies n'essaie pas
seulement de gagner constamment des
nouveaux clients il essaie surtout de
garder les clients déjà acquis sur le
long terme et pour ça il faut assurer de
ne pas créer la déception en ce qui est
communiqué aux consommateurs et
l'expérience finale qu'il aura avec la
marque il ya donc zéro intérêt emile
inconvénient pour une grande marque de
faire de la publicité mensongère mais
c'est pas toujours évident à éviter vous
avez peut-être déjà entendu l'histoire
des consommateurs américains qui se
plaignait que red bull ne donne pas
réellement d elle alors évidemment on
trouve ça rigolo exagérée comme
situation parce qu'on vous dit ils sont
bêtes parce que c'est une façon parler
évidemment mais ça c'est juste la
manière dont ça a été médiatisé en fait
ce qu'on ltée la plainte elle accusait
la marque de publicité mensongère quand
elle affirme que sa boisson augmente les
performances la concentration et la
réactivité tout en faisant payer la
boisson plus cher pour cette raison
alors qu'en vrai aucune étude
scientifique ne prouve que red bull
apporte plus de bienfaits qu'une tasse
de café vagues bien crédule et nie de
son côté toute intention de nuire et
affirmé que son marketing remplissait
tous les critères définis par la loi
ils ont finalement trouvé un accord avec
les plaignants pour éviter de faire plus
de bruit et de créer la confusion avec
un procès qui serait médiatisé est
mauvais pour l'image de la marque
ils ont accepté de distribuer 13
millions de dollars entre les
consommateurs chaque américain s'étant
senti déçu de la promesse de red bull
entre 2010 et 2014 pouvaient alors
demander 10 dollars de dédommagement et
en 2019 à canada qui trouvais ça injuste
que seuls les américains aient été
remboursés à attaquer red bull pour les
mêmes raisons et red bull a dû payer une
deuxième fois cette fois pour les
canadiens et pour une période couvrant
2007 à 2019
et oui on pourrait on pourrait le faire
ici oui vous l'aurez compris en tant que
grosses marques ne vaut mieux pas jouer
avec les consommateurs
du coup à qui ça pourrait profiter de
faire la publicité mensongère trompeuses
ou déloyales qui peut vouloir le faire
délibérément ben n'importe quelle
nouvelle marque a connu qui cherche à
faire et normandes profits très vite
avant de disparaître tout aussi vite
la publicité mensongère peut servir un
intérêt financier à court terme c'est la
stratégie de beaucoup des commerces
house avait tous ces trucs envoyer les
pubs sur instagram facebook et qui
repose souvent sur du drop shipping en
soi dropshipping ce n'est pas illégal un
pour rappel ou pour ceux qui le savent
pas ça consiste à choisir un produit sur
un site de vente pas cher lui créer un
nom et un marketing fort pour le vendre
plus cher et empocher la marche de vente
en gros et peut présenter une montre
comme une montre de luxe a indiqué aux
clients qu'il peut l'avoir un prix
exceptionnel de 79 euros au lieu du prix
barrés 429 euros dans une période
limitée de temps alors qu'à la base le
vendeur aura sélectionné une montre qui
coûte 9 euros sur un site de vente pas
cher mais c'est pas tout parce que les
gens qui commandent sur le beau site le
produit plus cher active automatiquement
une commande sur le site de vente
hr et du coup bah y'a aucun stock à
gérer c'est super simple
en gros il investit juste dans de la
publicité sur les réseaux sociaux alors
le troc shipping ça peut être certes mal
vu mais en vrai c'est juste du commerce
pas du tout illégale par contre mentir
sur les 4 p de son mix marketing soit
productrice place pour nos jeunes ça
c'est les gars c'est pour ça qu'après
avoir fait massivement beaucoup de
ventes il supprime souvent tout sans
laisser de traces sans même vérifier que
les acheteurs ont reçu leur colis et
refont un nouveau business autre part
avec un nouveau produit et un nouveau
break est en fait le drop shipping c'est
similaire sur pleins poids au téléachat
la télévision au téléachat c'était
souvent des produits achetés en grosse
quantité pas cher et brenda avec un nom
différent dont les mairies du produit
était beaucoup trop exagérés et qu'ils
vendraient à prix barrés dans une
période limitée de temps le télé achat
c'est un peu du drop shipping avant leur
enfer
ah oui et encore on dans le temps vous
souvenez des bracelets power balance ces
trucs là on disait que c'était des
bracelets dit énergétique
alors d'après sylvain rey quand le
produit utilisé une technologie
holographique exclusive basée sur une
philosophie orientale et servant apporte
un bienfait sur l'énergie naturelle du
corps sur notre force notre souplesse et
notre équilibre
c'est un produit qui est rapidement
devenu viral notamment grâce au
placement de produit chez des célébrités
qui le positionnait comme un accessoire
de mode
le bracelet power balance a été vendu à
plusieurs millions d'exemplaires à
travers les états unis et plus de 40
pays cependant aucune méthode
scientifique ne permettait de prouver
les effets prétendu du bracelet c'est
pourquoi en 2010 le bracelet a commencé
à faire polémique et de nombreuses
plates ont fait surface dans le monde
entier la répression des fraudes
australienne a contraint la société à
reconnaître qu'elle faisait de la
publicité mensongère et à payer
plusieurs millions de dollars
après ce jugement power balance belgique
s'est présentée comme indépendante de
power balance usa et à continuer à
vendre ses produits et c'est toujours le
cas actuellement mais pourquoi comment
qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien si power
balance se vend toujours actuellement en
belgique c'est parce que le marketing
est très différent il ne vend pas des
bienfaits le bracelet présenté avant
tout comme un objet esthétique et
ciblant les sportifs sans argument
particulier ce n'est donc pas de la
publicité mensongère c'est un peu le
même débat avec la lithothérapie par
exemple alors si vous n'êtes pas la
lithothérapie c'est une discipline qui
consiste à se soigner à grâce à des
cristaux comme l'améthyste la citrine
legs marine le rubis le turquoise et
consorts les promoteurs de la
lithothérapie explique que les cristaux
et met naturellement une résonance qui
serait capable d'améliorer le bien-être
d'une personne s'ils sont proches d'elle
un cristal agirait selon son type sur la
fréquence vibratoire de certains points
du corps c'est pire se porte en
pendentif en collier ou en bracelet mais
elle peut aussi être disposés dans une
pièce plus le coût de la pierre est
élevé plus la pierre aurait de grandes
capacités et les pierres peu cher aurait
les capacités moins grand comme par
hasard
du coup si la valeur d'achat influence
directement le pouvoir des cristaux ça
me semble important de savoir si c'est
vérifiable ces fameux pouvoir
[Musique]
alors ça n'a pas été vérifiée en tout
cas l'énergie des pierres il ya bien une
étude en 2001 ils ont tenté avec 80
volontaires je crois il en rend fou
turin cristal de quartz dans la main et
ils ont envoyé tout le monde aller
méditer pendant 10 minutes et puis notez
après vos sensations et du coup en fait
les gens ont quasiment tous trouvé une
sensation de chaleur dans la main au
niveau du cristal et un bien-être
général je crois que c'était 72 sur 80 à
noter ce genre de de sensations et
pelote triste c'est que la moitié des
cristaux en question c'était des fakes
était juste du plastique ce qui montre
c'est que c'est surtout l'effet conseil
contextuel donc tout ce qui est placebo
et compagnie qui aurait joué là dedans
en tout cas donc à ce jour il n'y a pas
de preuve scientifique de l'efficacité
de la lithothérapie et ce qui met en
avant général c'est vraiment le côté que
les pierres pourraient mettre une forme
d'énergie à ce jour la seule forme
d'énergie qu'on ait trouvé c'est la
radioactivité qui émane de certaines
pierre-jean l'uranie tca un minerai
d'uranium donc dans ce genre de cash que
des conseils si tu en as chez toi de te
le mettre autour du cou
du coup aucune preuve scientifique pour
l'efficacité de la thérapie ou même pour
l'existence de l'énergie spécifiques à
ces cristaux pourtant certains ouvrages
influent présente la lithothérapie de
façon beaucoup trop surestimer ce qui a
forcément une influence sur le marché de
ces cristaux dans le guide pratique de
la lithothérapie que l'on peut trouver
dans plusieurs grandes enseignes au
rayon bien-être on peut découvrir des
cristaux servant à traiter le sida
c'est évidemment faux la lithothérapie
ne pouvant soigner aucune réelle maladie
quelle qu'elle soit que l'on vienne le d
du coup là c'est un problème que les
associations de lutte contre le sida
n'ont pas du tout apprécié d'ailleurs un
site de vente en ligne qui vendraient
des pierres et qui aurait ce genre de
discours pour les vendre aurait de gros
soucis vendre les pierres en promettant
un bienfait non fondées et de la
publicité mensongère
ce n'est cependant pas un souci si ce
qui vend les pierres ne promettrai un
sauveur bien fait et vont juste des
pierres ça n'est pas de la publicité
mensongère et ne sont pas responsables
de ce qui est dit dans certains ouvrages
même s'ils peuvent ans et même ouvrage
aussi sur leur site
suivent et puis même si on souhaite en
parler en sa boutique promettre au
conditionnel compte
i que ça rendrait plus en forme c'est
pas la même chose que de dire arrêtez
votre traitement contre le cancer pour
vous soigner uniquement avec des pierres
en bresse une personne normale et sans
aidé par la soi-disante énergique va lui
apporter une pierre même si c'est basé
sur un effet contextuelle et placebo
tant que cette personne n'avait pas tout
son argent là dedans et qu'il achète ça
sur un site qui vend juste des pierres
sans rien promettre tout va bien dans ce
cadre un suspense qui est communiquée
avant l'acte d'achat au consommateur ça
peut donc être légal ou illégal
maintenant à partir de tout ce qu'on a
appris on va faire une annonce pour
notre météorite afin de la vente de
gagner de l'argent et pour ça va donc
découvrir un autre type de publicité
mensongère
larnack entre particuliers sur les sites
d'annoncés alors il faut qu'on fasse une
annonce en mentant pour être sûr de la
vente très vite mais tout en restant
dans la légalité pour ne pas avoir de
problème pour ça on va utiliser l'art du
copywriting le copywriting c'est l'art
de séduire et de persuader avec les mots
il est inventée par les plus grands
publicitaires durant les années
cinquante et un bon un coup bas coût
total en dire des conneries tu me
remercieras pas de t'avoir interrompue
vous les marketeux qu'est ce que vous
feriez pas pour vendre des deux tapis
quand même c'est un truc de ouf
mais j'étais juste en bref ça fait
l'accord du jld c'est pas moi c'est vous
vous alliez faire une bonne affaire est
dégagé mais laisse faire les gens qui
ont des compétences
ça va bien le copywriting une technique
pour persuader avec les mots inventés
par les grands marketeux des années 50
ans mais qu'est ce qu'il faut pas
entendre quand même hein parce que
persuadé par les mots c'est vieux comme
le monde et ça s'appelle la rhétorique
en fait plus précisément le mot
rhétorique vient du grec ancien
rhétorique et techno signifiant
techniques oratoires
d'où le mot rhéteur en français pour
désigner ceux qui sont bons en discours
aristote a beaucoup écrit dessus
la rhétorique en fonction de qui la
pratique vise deux fonctions celle de
bien parler c'est l'éloquence et celle
de convaincre c'est la persuasion et de
sont presque toujours lié et dans
l'antiquité on associer alors la
rhétorique à la politique et la justice
les personnages comme aristote et anna
ximen chez les grecs comme quintilien et
six saisons chez les romains ont
beaucoup écrit sur cette pratique
langage et j'en suis le dogme des
sophistes qui sont des orateurs et
professeur de rhétorique de la grèce
antique parler ne sert pas à expliquer
mais à convaincre pardon je mette je
mets tout fait que ma salive
ainsi il étudie à l'abord des stratégies
pour séduire un auditoire avec les mots
mettant le but de persuasion au dessus
de celle de dire la vérité du
copywriting connaît dans le domaine de
la publicité on peut remarquer quelques
constructions qui en français permet de
viser cet effet deux conditions sont
jamais totalement trahir la vérité
clessé d'utiliser à outrance de
modalités c'est à dire d'éléments qui
permettent d'injecter du subjectif dans
un énoncé pour connaître notamment le
rapport de l'interlocuteur par rapport à
ce qu'il énonce c'est une définition
très large mais regardez par exemple la
phrase suivante
j'aime les chats désormais prenez celle
ci bien sûr j'aime les chats dans la
seconde bien sûr est un modélisateur il
apporte une information ou un jugement
sur la seconde partie de l'énoncé
évidemment que j'aime les chats pas vous
dans le cadre la publicité on va
utiliser deux types de constructions
modale des verbes au conditionnel plutôt
qu à l'indicatif car le conditionnel
permet de sortir du cadre la réalité ou
de la vérité il est alors plus facile
d'émettre une hypothèse un jugement
injecter de la subjectivité dans le
propos il aimerait les chats on peut
même faire usage de semis auxiliaires
modo comme devoir au pouvoir qui
utilisait comme tel apporte une dose
d'incertitude en plus ils devraient
aimer les chiens et puis il ya les
adverbes modo les constructions
adverbiale en général tout simplement
selon les informations que j'ai pu
trouver il devrait aimer les chats on
peut aussi substitué les conditionnels
avec les adverbes comme probablement
peut-être sans doute il aime
probablement les chats c'est ce que j'ai
cru entendre en tout cas c'est fort
possible
sait-on jamais ça se trouve la personne
dont on parle des tests les chats mais
il nous en coûte rien formulé ces
énoncés nous dénonçons aucune vérité bon
alors alors on va jouer sur la beauté la
pierre avec un visuel retouché au niveau
des couleurs pour qu'elles ressortent
pour montrer qu'on est sur du luxe on va
mettre un prix qui semble cher pour ce
que c'est laid pour le justifier on va
créer le mystère avec un nombre pour la
non ce qui est pierre inconnu qui est
neutre et donc par un mensonge
ensuite on va se dédouaner en expliquant
que lapierre vient de quelqu'un d'autre
et ça ça a permis de créer du
storytelling
après on va placer une figure d'autorité
pour convaincre grâce aux spécialistes
mais qui n'aura été par les cas votre
ami sur qui vous vous des douanes on va
expliquer que ce prix qui semble énorme
et en fait seulement un quart de sa
vraie valeur pour donner l'impression de
faire une bonne affaire
après tout ça on va se justifier pour
diminuer la méfiance avec un prétexte un
peu vague en rappelant à celui qui le
lit que il est vraiment malin s'il
saisit l'occasion qui va forcément faire
une bonne affaire
et la petite touche ont créé un second
compte et en propose une offre à 160
euros pour faire croire qu'il ya
d'autres gens intéressés à si on croit
que la demande est supérieure à l'offre
et ça créera
un sentiment d'urgence alors regardez
pierre inconnu 200 euros un ami a trouvé
cette pierre dans son jardin selon un
spécialiste qu'il connaît il s'agirait
d'un cristal précieux ou vertus
médicinales pouvant valoir jusqu'à 800
euros vu son poids
je n'ai pas le temps de la faire
expertiser c'est pourquoi je vous la
laisse pour 200 euros soit un quart de
son prix estimé à saisir et ça ça veut
dire quoi ça ça veut dire qu'il a déjà
vendu
et ça marche bien le marketing
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si
elle vous a plu pouvait mettre un pouce
en l'air la partager commenter vous
abonner mettre la cloche et puis si vous
avez envie d'en parler davantage que
nous rejoindre sur le discorde du vortex
[Musique]
et si vous voulez qu'on continue à
parler de publicité mensongère
venez je suis au moment de la sortie de
cette vidéo en live sur ma chaîne twitch
le lien s'affiche ici où il est dans la
description et voilà venez on va
s'amuser c'est la pure vérité
non non non